this is a living breathing world of
fantasy based on reality built with
groundbreaking and cutting-edge
technology this is the ultimate action
RPG created for fresh faces to the
series as well as longtime fans this is
the grand quest to reclaim your throne
this is final fantasy 15
final fantasy 15 is set in the war-torn
world of a Yas you are noctus the crown
prince of the kingdom of lucious and
your quest is a seize back your homeland
from the clutches of the menacing
Imperial Army nifflheim that was an
attack the King was found dead
noctus and his three loyal companions
must embark on an epic journey of
brotherhood exploration and action as
they arrive on noctis's destiny and take
up arms against the invading nifflheim
empire
noctus is heir to the throne and the
only son of king regis his dislike of
the restrictions of the royal family and
his casual attitude belies a strong
desire to protect those around him in
combat not just wield spectral weapons
which he forges from thin air a power
possessed by those of his royal line
now is not the time to question your
call
noctus his friend Prompto is the life
and soul of the team fast friends would
noctis if they met as teenagers Prompto
is a young man of common birth who finds
himself out of his depth when tragedy
befalls alesis he go back to Sami and
I'll be safe for us there I might not be
safe for us here although he's the
weakest and youngest member of the team
his masterful gunplay makes prompt to a
valuable ally during skirmishes prompt
dose favorite hobby is photography and
the photos he takes on your journey can
be shared on social networks this one's
pretty good I think it too
and gladiolus noctis's eldest companion
and his family as long served as the
shield protecting the kings of lucious
however the bond Gladio shares of noctus
Tran says that of a bodyguard in his
leash Joxer
Gladius strength VZ can charge at the
enemy's ranks and wreak havoc over a
wide area
as a survivalist Gladio will retrieve
ever more useful items at the end of
battles as his ability develops when you
can't focus my focus for you it's my job
Ignace is the most thoughtful of
noctis's companions and was raised
alongside the prince to be advisor to
the heir apparent I'll analyze what
intelligence we have available you to
find us away in when it comes to
fighting he wields eel daggers with
deadly efficiency igneous can also mark
multiple enemies on the field setting up
noctus to warp strike each of them in
succession
as the team cook he crafts dishes that
would impress any restaurant with their
look smell and taste while also offering
stat bonuses to the party who have come
up with a new recipe
there is a strong supporting cast in
Final Fantasy 15 weaving a complex and
compelling story the principal
characters include Luna Princess up
tenebra and lifelong friend obnoxious
she is also the youngest Oracle in
history with an inborn ability to speak
to the gods regis the fallen king of
Lucis and his adversaries evilest and
Arden Emperor and Chancellor nifflheim
respectively provide the backbone to the
overall story filled with treachery
violence and mystery
Final Fantasy 15 combat system offers an
intoxicating blend of magic spells
summons and real-time battle action user
friendly and with hidden depths the
system lets you strike not only with a
vast array of hardware magic but to also
exploit the skills and weaponry of their
comrades
but don't forget to have a solid defense
where parrying and countering and
dodging your foes attacks will also be
key to victory
using noctis's unique Wharf ability then
quickly get into the action with a
long-range attack our deftly dodge
incoming attacks you can also warp out
to safety to assess the battlefield part
of our game precious health for those
who would prefer to slow things down
while in the heat of battle there's
weight mode while in weight mode the
player can pre leave target enemy's aim
magic spells select teammate abilities
and more
we after this time throughout your
travels you will also find and be able
to purchase powerful weapons and
accessories for noctis in the game you
can map different weapons and magic to
the d-pad meaning they can be easily
switched during combat to suit your
personal fighting style last but
certainly not least your choice of
outfit can also support you in combat
noctus and his comrades can be fully
customized with the range of outfits all
of which come with their own unique stat
boosts
magic will be an important weapon in
your arsenal and is collected from
elemental spots throughout the map it
can be crafted and loaded into the
inventory at a set amount of your choice
the more you invest into a specific
magic type the stronger and more
effective it will become when used in
battle
magic can also be combined with other
items to give us special attributes
on fire today
as you journey through Final Fantasy 15
the party will earn ability points by
leveling up and completing quests
these are used in the ascension system
to activate nexuses that will grant the
characters new and exciting skills to
aid you on your journey customized
nachus in the party to match your
playing style
of course no Final Fantasy game would be
complete without the power of summon
beings in Final Fantasy 15 you can
summon ferocious and on spiring beings
called
Astral's seeking them out and calling
upon their powers will provide
earth-shattering strength for your
bowels
the world of Eos is so epic that you'll
need to do more than explore only on
foot to enable your road trip of a
lifetime
you have the most extravagant of cars
which you can't to take it for a little
test drive if knocked the regalia is
your main mode of transport it will
allow you pass passage between major
locations but to get close to the action
and explore in depth you'll have to do
so on foot or by a chocobo
oh and by the way from a certain point
in the journey it'll be possible for the
regalia to fly
Final Fantasy 15 includes a plethora of
side quests which are available to you
throughout your journey some will relate
to the main story giving information on
other happenings in the world and
insight into the many characters you'll
meet along the way
tipsters in the world can be the
opportunity to carry out monster hunts
to gain valuable experience and a cash
reward your hunter rank increases as you
complete these quests which in turn
allows you to undertake more challenging
hunts with even greater rewards happy
hunting
havens are locations done throughout EOS
where the gang can safely recuperate
from the day's events make a camp at
these locations and utilizing mrs.
cooking skills to create delicious and
stat boosting meals
at various locations in the world you'll
find the game justice monsters 5 hugely
popular with noctus and the residents of
lusus this pinball game is fully
playable and final fantasy 15 and is
also available to download now on mobile
devices along with justice monsters 5
there are many other minigames to
discover and enjoy such as fishing why
not try your hand at catching the
evening dinner you did good
while exploring a vast realm of Eos you
will experience a world of wonder filled
with beauty tragedy and excitement play
again at that time Final Fantasy 15
retains the legendary hallmarks of the
Final Fantasy series which has
captivated players for nearly 30 years
while bringing you revolutionary
gameplay which has been developed with
pioneering technology joined by your
closest friends take the wheel and
embark on an epic adventure to fulfill
your destiny fresh faces a longtime fans
alike take back your throne and
experience a brand new kind of fantasy
[Music]
you
[Music]